the decades progress in AI has been
measured by how well we've succeeded in
playing the game to the humans play
we've already created systems that can
learn to master chess and go
and many people views starcraft as the
next grand challenge for the AI
community a couple of months ago we made
an explicit choice to try and scale up
and speed up the Starcraft project the
way we went about that was you have
different versions of the agent compete
against each other on something we call
the alpha star League this one learning
to beat that one this one learning to
beat that one and that leads them to
improve rapidly over time and discover
new strategies the wave played you could
see it was getting Starcraft has
imperfect information and is played in
real time it also requires long-term
planning and the ability to choose what
action to take from millions and
millions of possibilities
[Music]
we were able to be Danny the best the
mind starcraft2 player that definitely
exceeded expectations the next step is
we can a book in a pro to play I think
there's nothing better than you know a
big external test like that to focus the
mind if they can already beat me that
would be incredible I really thought TLO
would you know beat us no matter what
happens just well done it's been amazing
progress really amazing our goal is not
just to defeats these players alcohol is
to do it in the right way good a little
nervous because unlike a human player
alpha star can see the whole map at once
but we spoke with TLO and created as
level a playing field as he's currently
possible in particular alpha star can't
react quicker than human player can nor
net execute more actions clicks per
minute that human player all right
[Music]
I haven't really seen a pro play
Starcraft up close the 800 clicks per
minute
I don't understand how you will clean
clip 800 times let alone doing 800
useful clicks after the first match and
Univ was on that I actually have to work
pretty hard to to beat this thing I
didn't want to lose credibly this just
even held off I was surprised how strong
the agent was
[Music]
I actually lost every single on the fire
matches you enjoy hopefully I'll get to
have a rematch where I get to play my
strongest race well then I think I would
be the TLO is an amazing player but he
plays zerk and our Asians they produce
for now with TLO they were still that
but at the end of it you know but he's a
zag player and so now we've addressed
that back
I guess they need a protest specialist
and that's why I'm here I'm hoping for a
5-0 not to lose any games but I think
the realistic goal would be four and one
in my favor I think he looks more
confident and here I was quite nervous
before
[Music]
the room was much more tense this time I
really didn't know what to expect
he's been playing starter pretty much
since he's five
I wasn't expecting AI to be that good
everything that you did was proper it
was calculated and it was done well I
thought I'm learning something it's much
better than I expected it I would
consider myself a good player right but
I lost every single one on fire
we're way ahead of what I thought we
would do given where we were team on
scattering
she's trying to digest it all actually
but it's very very cool I think that
progress has been on touch that it's
humbling knowing how many people are
working on this project we'll start out
to some of the top minds of the world
these complexities are important to us
because they're representative of
something bigger the representative of
challenges that face the whole of AI
which haven't yet been solved I think
everybody's just very excited to see
what comes out of this and hopefully
that Starcraft is going to be a part of
history when it comes to a iron
[Music]